[Music]
[Music]
hey wait up dude man the door thing he
broke again I guess it's just eat
I could probably hit that target up
there with my crossbow LSP
yeah yeah Wow globbit now how am I gonna
get up to get my grass sword on
[Music]
[Music]
check it out
a magical globe no thin it's what you
can swing through the globe golly look
you see this book yeah I see it it's
called the enchiridion it's a movement
only for heroes whose hearts are
righteous shmow-zow the book lies at the
top of mount cragdor guarded by a manly
Minotaur it's waiting for a truly
righteous hero to claim it do you think
I've got the goods bubblegum cuz I am
into this stuff yeah I know
and yes I do math creaking jung-hee
knows to be this mountain is called
cragdor its purpose is twofold to
protect the entire grid Ian and to test
the hearts of those who seek to possess
it many noble challenges Avengers
attempting to pass the grueling trials
that I beyond these walls but no one has
ever left here alive or dead only the
truest most worthy hero can receive the
heroes and guide it is your friend oh
and I cannot say that I am certain that
you already be welcome to try however
first you must pass my riddle oh you've
unlocked the riddle in the door child
you've passed the first trial young
heroes for prepare yourselves for there
are many trials ahead of you and each
trial is more treacherous than the last
what you got Jake hmm I'm thinking some
wheels
hey you're not busy are you
[Music]
[Music]